with the design
it
you
dear friends we are gathered here today
to pray for to pay our respects to and
to share our sorrow at the departure of
Jacqueline Kennedy Onassis so dearly
beloved so sorely missed there's an old
saying in the church that for those who
died in the faith of Christ a funeral is
as much for the consolation of the
living as it is for the comfort of the
deceased
so in this hour of parting let us
remember the everlasting dawn of God's
presence in heaven as we pray for
Jacqueline and for ourselves and now
remarks by the President of the United
States
we are joined here today at the site of
the eternal flame lit by Jacqueline
Kennedy Onassis 31 years ago to bid
farewell to this remarkable woman whose
life will forever glow in the lives of
her fellow Americans whether she was
soothing a nation grieving for a former
president or raising a children with the
care and the privacy they deserve are
simply being a good friend
she seemed always to do the right thing
in the right way she taught us by
example about the beauty of art the
meaning of culture the lessons of
history the power of personal courage
the nobility of public service and most
of all the sanctity of family God gave
her very great gifts and imposed upon
her great burdens she bore them all with
dignity and grace and uncommon common
sense in the end she cared most about
being a good mother to her children
and the lives of Carolina and John leave
no doubt that she was that and more
Hillary and I are especially grateful
that she took so much time to talk about
the importance of raising children away
from the public eye and we will always
remember the wonderful happy times we
shared together last summer
with admiration love and gratitude for
the inspiration and the dream she gave
to all of us we say goodbye the Jackie
today made the flame she lit so long ago
burn ever brighter here and always
brighter in our hearts god bless you
friends and farewell
and now a reading from scripture by John
Kennedy
so reading from the second letter of
Saint Paul to the Thessalonians but I
would not have you to be ignorant
brethren concerning them which are
asleep that you sorrow not even as
others which have no hope for if we
believe that Jesus died and rose again
even so them also which sleep in Jesus
will God bring with him for this we say
unto you by the word of the Lord that we
which are alive and remain unto the
coming of the Lord shall not prevent
them which are asleep for the Lord
himself shall descend from heaven with a
shout with the voice of the Archangel
and with the Trump of God and the dead
in Christ shall rise first then we which
are alive and remain shall be caught up
together with them in the clouds to meet
the lord in the air and so shall we ever
be with the Lord wherefore comfort one
another with these words
this is the word of the Lord
now the reading of a responsorial Psalm
by carolyn kennedy Schlossberg and the
response to this responsorial Psalm is I
lift up my eyes to the mountains
I will lift up mine eyes unto the hills
from whence cometh my help
my help cometh from the Lord which made
heaven and earth I will lift up my
horizons he will not suffer thy foot to
be moved he that keepeth thee will not
slumber
behold he that keepeth Israel shall
neither slumber nor sleep I will lift up
mine eyes to the mountain the Lord is
thy keeper the Lord is thy shade upon
thy right hand the Sun shall not smite
thee by day nor the moon by night I will
lift up my eyes to the hills the Lord
shall preserve thee from all evil he
shall preserve thy soul the Lord shall
preserve thy going out and thy coming in
from this time forth and even
forevermore I will lift up my mouth
now let us all join in the recitation of
the Lord's Prayer our Father who art in
heaven hallowed be thy name thy kingdom
come thy will be done on earth as it is
in heaven give us this day our daily
bread and forgive us our trespasses as
we forgive those who trespass against us
and lead us not into temptation but
deliver us from evil
in the ancient cemeteries of the
Christians in Rome called catacombs the
inscriptions on the tombs showed their
belief
generally they inscribed just the name
of the deceased person with the words
diaz natales in domino that is birthday
in the Lord and then after that simply
the date of death of the person not the
date of birth in this life
and so for us May the 19th was the
birthday in the Lord of Jacqueline
Kennedy Onassis
and we remember that as we recite this
final prayer and blessing
thank you
Oh God the author of the unbought race
of life you are our promised home lead
your servant Jacqueline to that home
bright with the presence of your
everlasting life and love they are to
join the other members of her beloved
family console also those who have
suffered the loss of her mortal presence
give them the grace that will strengthen
the bonds of the family and of our
national community may we bear your
peace to others until the day we join
you and all the saints in your life of
endless love and light we ask this in
the name of Christ our Lord
eternal rest grant unto her O Lord and
let perpetual light shine upon her may
she rest in peace and may her soul and
all the souls of a faithful departed
through the mercy of God rest in peace
and with the blessing of Almighty God
the Father God the Son and God the Holy
Spirit descend upon her and us now and
forever amen
it's a mighty ocean he hear us when we
cry to thee Oh
along the sea
you can use
you
II
this graveside ceremony for Jacqueline
Kennedy Onassis will rear at 1:20 a.m.
and 655 both Eastern Times
you